[Music]
what
well hello dear friends uh Welcome to
our program I'd like to know a question
and answer program that airs once a week
we do appreciate you sending us your
questions let me give you the address
where you can send them to us it's an
electronic address
TVM tv.org
TVM tv.org you'll see it there on the
screen we would be delighted to get your
questions we do the research and then we
do our best to try and answer those
questions on the air uh please remember
also that these programs uh have a cost
to produce we do appreciate everyone's
financial support so that we can
continue the quality program that is
produced here at Secrets unsealed I have
with me here Pastor David Salasar uh who
is in charge of our Hispanic Outreach of
sutv and it's always a pleasure to have
him with us thank you um you know he
came to us uh recently along with his
beautiful family uh his wife helps a
helps a lot here at Secrets unsealed at
some TV and it's a real joy to have you
here uh for this program and also for
all of the programs of some TV and
secrets unsealed thank you Pastor it
always a blessing and a privilege for me
to share this uh set with you and to be
able to answer the questions God willing
to give uh insight to those that are
asking and you know from the word of God
to give them an assurance and a good
answer that will help them spiritually
amen praise the Lord uh would you please
have prayer for us as we begin
absolutely thank you let us pray
Heavenly Father Lord as we come before
you at this hour we thank you for anow
allowing us to uh study your word and to
be able to answer the questions that
many friends have sent in in ourselves
we don't have the knowledge we don't
have the answers but we know that you do
and we want to point the heart and the
minds of those that are watching to your
word and to you so help us to give
answers that will glorify honor your
name and bring them closer to a
understanding of the scriptures we pray
all these in Jesus name amen amen you
know sometimes we get questions that
don't have a direct um answer in the
Bible or the spirit of Prophecy for that
matter and such is uh the first question
that we're going to deal with today uh
and I want to read it and then I'm going
to throw it to you you and see what kind
of research you did on this particular
Point sure uh it's sent To Us by Karen
uh there's no mention of a location and
this is what it says Hi I was watching
your program I'd like to know and you
were talking about unclean foods and one
of you I don't know who it would be
because we have different people here on
the panel one of you mentioned mushrooms
are they unclean that we should not eat
them if so please explain why so
basically the question is uh are
mushrooms unclean and should we not eat
mushrooms okay so what can we say about
that well pastor this is a question that
has in my experience has come to me in a
couple of times and usually the concern
which I think is valid for people that
are questioning or wondering about
mushrooms are they safe to eat uh there
is this idea by some people and I
respect again the research unfortunately
there's not a uh like you mentioned
there's not an answer from the SC
prophecy not once sister white speaks of
mushrooms uh we don't have also in the
Bible necessarily anything that deals
with the word mushroom again or or
specifically speaking of that but uh and
because of this like I said there is
this uh maybe some people side with idea
through science through regular science
that mushrooms are not very good to eat
first of all because there's a lot of
mushrooms that are poisonous we know
that there's and there's mushrooms that
are actually can cause hallucinations
and and are used in many ways to uh give
you know bring people into a like a
trans in a way you know and they use in
this occultic way so because of that
some people have said mushrooms are not
good to eat another reason is because
mushrooms belong to the fungi family and
in biology the fungi kingdom fungi
family it's a little more associated
with animals than with plants and
because of the closer characteristic to
a animal in in a sense they say is is
unclean but let's to be honest you know
if we do a very good or try to do a um
objective analysis of mushrooms first of
all we have to understand that mushrooms
uh belong to this Kingdom family which
is the funi family biology and this
kingdom is by itself in other words it's
not belong to the plant kingdom neither
in the Animalia Kingdom or animals
Kingdom and it's it's a kingdom that
actually has three different types the
yeast family the mol family and the
mushroom family so this funi family has
all all these three so for example if
yeast now yeast there are good yeast and
there's bad yeast and the good good
yeast you use for making bread you know
we use yeast for bread and that is
actually found in the word of God you
know you have the yeast and people will
eat bread and and yeast was not
necessarily A A forbidden thing to eat
you could eat it and under molds you
have a lot of bad molds absolutely but
there's good ones uh for example the
antibiotic pen penicillin which was uh
found by accident in a sense in a mold
is actually an
antibiotic you know know subst substance
and so then we have the mushrooms and
that's where mushrooms there is plenty
of mushrooms that are wrong and are are
poisonous and you name it but there are
some who actually have benefits and some
of the benefits that they have found is
that they are high in vitamin B you know
and in many people that they say there
there's there's some studies that
suggest that some mushrooms can help you
with uh uh memor memory with uh some
symptoms on emotional you know stability
and things of that nature a lot of
things you can research in online about
it so I will suggest that since there is
no um clear definition the Bible the
best thing for you is to do some
research yourself you know find out in
science and if you don't feel
comfortable if you don't like them don't
eat them you know there's no need to be
eating something you don't like because
I know Pastor B you particularly don't
care for mushrooms that much you know I
you know I'll eat them yeah I don't hate
mushrooms uhhuh but but they're not my
favorite food yes and um you know it has
nothing to do with whether they're
beneficial or not to my health uh it's
just that I don't like the taste yeah
you know it kind of reminds me of uh
President Bush the older President Bush
uh who uh publicly said that he didn't
like broccoli and shortly thereafter you
had several trucks park in front of the
White House with broccoli in them so I
don't want people to get the impression
and suddenly come to Secrets unsealed
with trucks full of mushrooms you know
it's just a matter of taste I might
mention that of course the Bible does
not mention mushrooms MH and I looked in
the writings of Ellen White and I was
not able to find a single reference to
mushrooms right in the writings of Ellen
White yeah I don't know if they were not
uh an item of Cuisine back then or the
reason why she wouldn't mention
mushrooms but I did look up a study that
was done at UCLA the University of
California Los Angeles mhm and it lists
a number of benefits of eating mushrooms
one is it decreases the r risk of cancer
according to studies that they did it
lowers sodium intake right it keeps
cholesterol levels low uh it's a good
source of vitamin D for strong bones and
calcium
absorption um it's uh stimulates a
healthy growth of healthy bacteria in
the body has Micron nutrients that
promote a healthy immune system mhm and
it protects brain health so it looks
like it has a lot of benefits physical
benefits you know many times when uh the
Bible and the spiritual prophecy don't
address something you know we need to
appeal to a different studies that were
done in the scientific field to find out
if it's beneficial so the bottom line is
we can't say the Bible States this or
Ellen White States this regarding
mushrooms we have to depend on studying
that have done been done and we have to
be very careful that we don't eat the
wrong kind of mushroom absolutely
absolutely and you know just to add
these little thing you mentioned Vitamin
D it is correct is the only source that
is NN from animal consumption that uh
vegans or vegetarians can eat uh for
vitamin D specifically so it it is one
of the things that you know if you need
Vitamin D in your diet you might not
find it another way but through
mushrooms so interesting things so yes
Pastor you're right about that well
sorry we couldn't Pro provide a Biblical
or Spirit of Prophecy answer to this
question we usually like to quote the
Bible and give uh Ellen White reasons
for certain questions uh but uh we did
the best we could under the
circumstances take into account that the
Bible does not mention anything about
mushrooms the Bible when it speaks about
the animal kingdom it does tell you
don't eat birds of prey uh you know it
tells uh you you can partake of uh birds
that are domestic uh even though we
really should not eat any flesh food uh
you know when it comes to fish it gives
prescriptions when it comes to uh you
know land animals it tells us what we
can eat and what we can't but with
regards to mushrooms yeah or other
veggies for that matter or other fruits
yeah very limited does really say okay
let's go to our next question M uh this
one comes from Ogden once again uh no
location
mentioned uh first thing we have to
agree this is actually a statement more
than a question first thing we have to
agree is that the day begins at the
sunset Genesis 1 verse5 we agree on that
we agree so why were they not working at
night God does not leave us to
procrastination he gives us the answer
let's journey to Psalms 104 from verse
19 to verse 23 verse 20 explains that
the purpose of the night was meant for
the beasts verse 23 now gives us the
reason
why man is to work from sunrise to
evening only as per God's plan so you
know the question is the syntax of the
question is not simple uh but what can
we say about the meaning of Psalm 104:
19 to 23 let me read them and we'll
answer I believe reading the whole
context will help help us understand
more clearly verse 19 says he appointed
speak of God he appointed the moon for
Seasons the sun knoweth he's going down
thou markest darkness and it is night
wherein all the beasts of the forest do
creep forth the Young Lions Roar after
their prey and seek their meat from God
the sun ariseth they gather themselves
together and lay them down in their dens
men goeth forth unto his work and to his
labor until the evening so here we have
a very you know the Bible describing
what happens at night you know how the
night in a sense was reserved for the
beasts that are you know nocturnal that
work at night that look for their prey
at night lions and actually specifically
using you know the Lions of lines they
tend to be night animals owls as well
you know owls work at night so there are
during the night there are animals who
that are by the Lord designed to work
and operate if if you will to do their
labor at night while men in most General
sense is to be asleep and to rest and
the night was given for us to rest for
more labor to get the strength and as
verse 23 mentions for men in most
general terms you know the idea is for
us to work during the day hours while
the Sun is up while the sun there's
sunlight that is our us for us the time
to labor and work so I believe that the
statement of this friend of ours is is
correct in that sense you know but we
cannot for sure say that men cannot work
at night you know there are now
specifically nowadays you know uh and
even back then uh necessity for people
to labor at night you know whether is
emergencies and medical emergencies or
uh soldiers to guard you know the city
so there are exceptions to that rule but
in general terms I believe Pastor you
know that this these verses are kind of
indicating us what the night was for uh
for the work of these nocturnal animals
while the day is mainly for mankind and
I believe that what he said is is what
we agree upon as well and you know there
are animals that are day animals yeah
you take for example butterflies right
you know uh butterflies they don't fly
around at night they don't they fly in
the daytime on the other hand moths that
have wings yes you know they fly around
at night so so it's not true that all
animals are night animals right
uh it mentions here lion which Lions go
and look for their prey at night right
owls yeah you know they're night animals
absolutely uh I think it's referring
primarily to animals of prey of prey
that roam at night yeah uh but you know
cows and horses and all kinds of other
animals uh they they are day animals uh
so the principle is that we are supposed
to as a rule work during the daylight
hours as well as some animals
right and the animals of prey they roam
around at night and also there are human
beings who um have to work at night I
mean you can't stop the work at
hospitals right at night because you
have emergencies that come in you have
patients that need to be taken care of
so there's some human beings that are
going to have to work at night yes and
uh so we need to be flexible we can't
take this as law of Mees and Persians
nobody works at night yeah you know
because there are circumstances that
require uh work at night I mean even
Christ himself uh met someone very late
at night you know I mean he was even
willing to work or in you know or or
labor for someone at night which was
Nicodemus he came at the middle of the
night and even Paul himself you know
when he was departing he they he stayed
up speaking and preaching all night so
you know there are exceptions and like
you said some people are needed to work
at night I mean that's how we keep the
electricity on you know there's a lot of
things that happen at night that we need
them to work for so and sometimes Jesus
was awake all night yeah we know that he
prayed all night yeah and so you know we
need to not be
inflexible when it comes to this and say
day or night you know there are
exceptional cases where some people are
going to have to work at night and
there's many animals that r during the
daytime right right so okay uh very good
uh we have another question now this is
from
cheyen uh writing from Chicago
Illinois uh was it only Aaron's sons and
the generation of the sons of Aaron that
could be priests and high priests and
the Levites weren't priests and high
priest but were to help maintain the
temple or were the Levites supposed to
be part of the temple services in some
way and did this change at any point to
where men other than the male
descendants of Aaron could be priests or
high
priests uh so the this question
basically is um you know the sons of
Aaron uh they were priests and is the
function of the priest and the levite
are the same or are they different okay
the first first thing I I think we need
to uh remind our our friends is that the
Levites
were the
tribe or or the descendants of the tribe
of Levi and as a tribe
God uh made them become his portion in
the children of Israel if we go to
numbers four and I'll read briefly just
uh or numbers three rather verse
45 God is there in that whole chapter
actually explaining how he's going to
divide the the tribes but in verse 45
says take the Levites he speaking to to
Moses take the Levites instead of all
the firstborn among the children of
Israel and the cattle of the Levites
instead of their cattle and the Levites
shall be mine I am the Lord so the Lord
selected the tribe of the Levi or the
Levites you know at the tribe of Levi to
be his tribe they would not have uh
territory they will not receive the any
place specifically to to live they were
not going to have a land they were
actually going to be for the use to the
Lord or for the Lord's service so this
is where God explains to them about that
specifically so then um we have to
understand that since they were the they
belong to the Lord they had a purpose
they were not just to um uh not do
anything of the idol they were to be the
ones that will teach the statutes the
teachings of God to the other tribes
they were to be the ones that will of
course as part of one of their portions
was to be the part of the priesthood as
well so they would have to service in
the temple whether it was in the um
different things that priests had to do
you know the uh taking care of the uh
animals uh the ceremony is the carrying
the this holy things of the Lord
receiving receiving the tithe re the
tithe as well because that was their
purpose they had to teach and as a
teachers as the ones that really led the
people to the truth or preach the truth
they were to live of that since they
have any land they had to stain by
tithing and another thing is uh that she
mentions asked the question is what
about the Aaron where the priesthood
from Aaron uh and his children only from
what we can understand it was yes to
Aaron and his Descendants the role of
priesthood That was supposed to be uh
for them for the specific family of the
Levites the Aaron priesthood was the one
that had the role of becoming the the
high priest and continue throughout the
generations so I don't know if um uh
there's actually a nice I looked at
there is a you know a levitical
priesthood and we can see that all the
desens of Aaron uh at one point or the
other even if they were removed from
priesthood like for example Eli who was
a descendant of Aaron the the priest Eli
in the time of Moses he received God
told him that his family would not be
forever in the priesthood and we know
that that happened his priesthood was
was expired or or or did not have any
descendants uh after the death of um I
think is ALC which was a descendant of
um Eli but
this this example this this this uh you
know person this this group of people
this family tree if you will uh was
stopped but God had another son of Aaron
who continued with the priesthood which
was the usel and and then you have more
and then you have elaser and FAS and
there's a lot of them that you go
through the lines a lot it's a long
story but yes ultimately we can see that
Aaron and his descend were the ones that
kept the priesthood and all the way till
uh the time of Christ even so we do have
that um experience in the genology it's
it's a lot of a lot of names a lot of uh
information but we can you know you can
request them to research and there is
actually a family tree a gen tree of the
branch of Aaron and we will see that all
the priests all the high priests I I
rather say were from that family
of Aaron yeah you know Hebrews chapter 7
MH uh 7 verse5 yeah says and indeed
those who are of the sons of
Levi who receive the
priesthood have a commandment to receive
tithes from the people yeah and so very
explicitly it says that the sons of Levi
M had the
priesthood and they received the tithes
um I like to think of the priests mhm as
the um as the pastors yes and the uh
Levites as the deacons yes that's
probably you you look at the function of
the Levites basically was to care for
the sanctuary to teach the people it was
to receive the tithe uh Etc which is
basically the role of of deacons in the
church these days that's right uh so um
you know in Hebrews chapter 7 makes it
clear that Jesus had no right to to the
priesthood mhm because he was from a
tribe of Judah exactly he was not from
the tribe of and so and so it was
necessary for Jesus to be a priest
according to a different order yeah and
so he was a priest forever according to
the order of mekc that's right so in
other words from melkisedek the order of
melkisedek Jesus gets the right to be a
priest and from the order of Judah he
has the right to be a king absolutely
pastor and you know the family of Aaron
was a priesthood there's families in
numbers four and you can you know we can
ask them to read that but in chapter
four we have uh there the family chapter
verse verse four the family of Kath the
kohathites and they were the ones that
you mentioned like the deacons they had
to take care of the packing of the
Tabernacle to the moving of the
Tabernacle things and then you have uh
the ones that from the family of the
Levites there was a family of singers
you know that would sing the ones that
were going to dedicate themselves to
create music as well so uh we have in
the Levites different families different
head families and they had different
roles for the organization of the work
of God for his whole nation and each
family had its role and you mentioned
some were the priests some were the ones
that will help the priests some were the
ones to teach some were to to deal with
music
but all of them were sustained by the
Tiding of the rest of the tribes so the
way that they will be able to sustain
themselves was first of all being
faithful to their call they had and you
know teaching the right way and teaching
other tribes how to live according to
God's will pointing them to the truth
all the time and the way they will
sustain was that they will receive the
Tiding from the children of Israel and
that way they could actually live and
sustain themselves but without having
land lands or or inheritance necessarily
okay there's another question here that
this same person sends if I sell my home
and do not plan to keep the earnings
from that cell
liquid but apply what is earned to the
purchase of my next house should I be
tithing this in some way and I can't
think the answer is pretty clear that
whatever the value of the house has
increased you would tie that absolutely
because Ely you know what you invested
in the house originally that money has
probably been tithed already right but
if the house is worth more than what you
bought it for then you would tithe the
increase in price of the of the house
absolutely if you receive an income an
increase in in you know in what you sell
like you sell it you bought it in 100
and you sell it in 200 well that 100
extra increase from that increase you
take a tiing that's what should be Yeah
so basically you know the the point is
that we should tithe based on the
increase our increase exactly and that
doesn't mean that we tithe from our net
after we paid for all of our
bills you know it means that we tithe
the uh total amount of the check that we
receive because that's an increase
exactly and uh and then of course uh we
tithe first and then we handle our
expenses after we have tithed I think
that is important to put you know where
you you know you're really where your
trust is you know tithing is about
relationship with God believing trusting
him and you tithe because you love God
you recognize that that 10% does not
even belong to you is his and you just
return it as an act of honesty but then
the Lord says there's also that offering
you should do and that's from a decision
of love to the Lord and if the lord gave
you an increase in in value property
value you should be thankful to the Lord
right and be happy to give it to him you
know what is his and and an offering as
well yeah the bottom line is that when
we tithe we're not being generous no
we're only being
honest but when it comes to offerings we
can be we should be generous that's
where we show whether we are being
generous with the Lord or not yeah uh
because because the offering comes to
the offerings that's uh discretionary on
our part uh and we're supposed to off
give offerings Accord according to the
blessings that God has given us right
and what are the blessings he has given
us well the first is salvation mhm you
know when we were lost we're saved now
uh and so uh you know we should be very
generous with our offerings amen and uh
and be honest with our tithe absolutely
praise the lord well our time is just
about up uh we want to thank you for
joining us today for a program I'd like
to know very engaging questions please
send us your questions to TVM tv.org and
we'll be looking forward forward to
answering those questions God bless see
you next
[Music]
time